Donald Trump went golfing this weekend
as coronavirus deaths are going to hit a
hundred thousand maybe they already have
by the time you're listening to this
maybe they are minutes from reaching
100,000 American coronavirus deaths
that's happening just weeks after Donald
Trump said the total total total death
toll would be 60,000 and I have to tell
you I understand the outrage I don't
really care about Trump's golf in
principle once again you know this
entire Trump golfing thing has become
like so many other things a proxy or a
signal for a different issue the issue
with Trump golfing is that he's failing
at almost everything and barely does any
work he often watches five hours of
cable TV in the morning strolls into
work around noon or even later if Trump
was leading a world-class coronavirus
response and he was playing golf I
wouldn't care who would really care if
the guy was doing a good job in keeping
Americans safe but he's not and so
there's that aspect and then there's as
almost always with Donald Trump there's
the aspect of incredible double
standards and hypocrisy Trump attacked
Barack Obama for golfing all the time
Obama golfed a fraction of what Trump
did and was never dealing with a global
pandemic with a hundred thousand
American death toll one example back in
2014
Donald Trump tweeted quote can you
believe that with all of the problems
and difficulties facing the u.s.
President Obama spent the day playing
golf and yet Donald Trump this weekend
as we approached the horrifying number
of 100,000 Americans death dead because
of coronavirus and in May
not in June or August as many models
predicted Donald Trump is golfing our
friend Brian class who's been a guest on
the show a couple of times posted a
collage on Twitter of the many times
Trump attacked Obama for golfing Obama
golfing while the TSA falls apart
Obama golfing you know while a marine is
in Mexico Obama golfing during Ebola
during which two people died so this is
not really about playing golf this is
about Trump's failures this is about
Trump's hypocrisy and this is about
Fromm's lethal in
competence Trump ran on I'm gonna be too
busy too rarely if ever leave the White
House when I'm president of the United
States but he's golfed more than anybody
Trump criticized his predecessor for
golfing even in the absence of anything
even remotely approximating a global
pandemic never mind a global pandemic on
which he has failed Trump said Obama
shouldn't be golfing when two people
died so I don't need the golfing to stop
I need the dangerous incompetence and
hypocrisy to end acting more quickly
would have saved so many lives getting a
working testing and contact tracing
program in place would have saved so
many lives there's a new study from
Columbia University which says that just
one week earlier for shutting down
restaurants and businesses could have
saved 35,000 of the hundred thousand
that have died so far 35 out of the
hundred thousand study from the
University of Southern California over
the last few days found similar numbers
made similar estimates looking at how
South Korea responded I mean I'm like a
broken record at this point
looking at South Korea is very very
relevant so yeah I mean the Golf Club
trips to his own clubs funnel money into
his family's pockets he's violating the
emoluments clause secret service by
renting all of those golf carts and then
paying Trump's own business for those
golf carts is just a way for Trump to
profit from his presidency it's not just
this way that he's violating the
emoluments clause that doesn't change
the taxpayers are paying for I get all
of it but the golf in and of itself is
not the issue it's the hypocrisy and the
degree to which Trump's incompetence and
laziness is now leading to a very real
death toll six-figure death toll in the
United States alone and he is continuing
to golf despite criticizing his
predecessor for doing it and saying he
wouldn't be golfing
it's the presidency that has to end let
him play all the golf he wants he can
play 36 72 holes a day if he wants once
we've removed him from office one of our
sponsors today is helix Slee
and it's a sponsor I'm thrilled about
because I sleep on a helix mattress at
home and it's just the perfect mattress
one of the best things about helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do I need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type your sleeping position your back
pain issues you might have and they will
pair you with a mattress that will be
perfect for you
I took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what I needed
I often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool it's not too soft
it's not too firm the texture is right
and I've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress every
decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a ten
year warranty and they'll even come to
your house and pick it up within a
hundred days if you don't love it but I
think you will all of my viewers will
get up to two hundred dollars off your
order and you'll get two super premium
pillows for free when you go to the link
right underneath this video